Hello everybody welcome back to the
channel uh the numbers are going good so
far for this whole systems design series
which is great because it keeps my
depression at Bay uh today I'm trying
something a little bit new with the iPad
where I kind of pre-draw most of the
stuff as to save everybody time not
having to wait for me drawing and also
it means my drawings are going to be a
little bit better I can put some more
thought into them so let's go ahead and
talk about some LSM trees and SS tables
and we can start learning all right
let's get started so today we're going
to be talking about an LSM tree which is
another type of database index that was
developed a little bit later in time
relative to the B tree which we talked
about in our last video so the kind of
main component of this LSM tree index
that we're going to start by looking at
is a red black or perhaps a b tree or an
AVL tree basically any balanced binary
search tree that is going to be put in
memory so I've drawn that out for us
below let's imagine we have a bunch of
students and their scores on the last
math test or computer science test or
whatever so we've got you know a bunch
of these guys as you can see because
it's about binary balance search tree we
know that for every single node all the
nodes to the left of it are going to
have a lower key and all of the notes to
the right of it are going to have a
higher key so we can see our invariant
has been satisfied so for now let's
imagine that all of the reads and rights
to and from the database are going to
this tree right so if I were to add this
key down here in red or maybe that's
orange I am colorblind we're going to go
ahead and add it under Chuck and to the
right of Chuck which is good it means
it's in the right place and what that
means is that all of these reads and
writes are going to be o of log n really
really good goes to memory which is very
fast okay but as we've discussed plenty
of times already just doing everything
in memory is not so simple so right now
we've got a couple of issues we have our
in-memory balance binary search tree
which like I said red black AVL B tree
any of those algorithms might work I'm
not going to cover them because they're
all pretty complicated and frankly I
don't even know them that well you can
do that on your own time
okay so a couple of things come up when
we have a tree that is in memory and
we've spoken about this in the past
especially as it pertains to Hash
indexes so there are two main issues the
first one is going to be that there is
no durability right that means if the
computer shuts down your index is
effectively lost and that is not going
to work for us so what are we going to
do well similarly to the hash index we
are going to use a write ahead log now
that is a sequentially written log that
we store on disk meaning that rights are
going to be relatively fast because we
don't have to jump all over the place on
disk and basically if it's going to be
the case that you know something like uh
you know the machine were to crash or
anything like that all we would do is go
ahead through the changes on the right
ahead log and replay them gradually
reformulating our LSM tree which is
really good so now we've covered
durability but it does come at the cost
of slower rates because now we have to
deal with disk i o okay the other big
issue is that we have less space for
hash indexes I basically just told you
to go yourself I said all the keys
have to fit in memory but for the LSM
tree itself there's actually a very
clever solution to this and this is
where this video actually starts to get
complicated so we've got this big thing
right here less space and the only way
we're going to get more space is by
starting to incorporate all of that
extra space that we have on disk so
let's go ahead and do something our LSM
tree has gotten too big let's say it
surpassed some threshold in bytes right
we know that that might be you know some
amount of kilobytes let's leave it at
that I'm not going to name an exact
amount that's for the researchers so
when that LSM tree gets too big we're
going to do two things first of all
we're going to reset it right we're
going to purge it of all the nodes in it
and then second of all we're going to
convert it to something called an SS
table and that is going to be on disk so
the SS table itself is basically the
following it is a conversion of our LSM
tree over here to the left to be sorted
in order with all of the scores kept the
same and that SS table is immutable once
we've converted this to an SS table
we're not touching the results of that
SS table we're just keeping it in disk
and I'll explain to you kind of how that
works in a second you may also say to
yourself damn isn't that a pretty
expensive operation to convert this tree
to a sorted list on disk sorting is
obviously very expensive if you have to
sort an array that is going to be o of n
log n at best well actually kind of the
really great part about us using a
binary search tree is the fact that we
can do an in-order traversal on it and
that's an algorithm that happens in
linear time I've literally written out
the pseudo code right here and what that
means is that by running our inorder
traversal we can get all of those nodes
in order so that we get this sorted
table relatively quickly we can write it
on disk and then we're done with it okay
so now we have our sorted table so to
just kind of give a bigger picture of
what's really going on here we have
basically the following right we've got
our LSM tree
which is in memory and then once that
becomes sufficiently big it's going to
get converted to SS tables so you see
now that we have multiple SS table files
because these are basically the
conversions of past LSM trees once
they've gotten too big and these again
are on disk okay so what is the point of
having all of these SS table files well
basically the main thing is that you
know all of our rights are going right
here into the LSM tree but when we're
reading we have to also incorporate
those SS table files so how are we
incorporating the SS tables basically
when we read the first thing that's
going to happen is we look for our key
in the LSM tree that's literally just a
tree traversal this is a binary search
tree we all know how to find a key in a
binary search tree so that's going to be
step one if our key isn't in there it
was perhaps written in the past right
maybe it's on one of our SS tables so
then we have to actually check the most
recent SS table and we have to check the
second most recent SS table if the key
happens to be in both of these tables
well it means that the one that was
written most recently is the most
up-to-date value of that key because
like I said SS tables are immutable if
we want to update a value we basically
just have to write it again and the same
thing actually goes for deleting a key
so what if we want to do a delete well
this is where we do something called a
tombstone
so I have it written down on the bottom
left of the screen right here for this
Tombstone let's imagine that I want to
delete the key Jordan so if you know the
key Jordan is in SS table 2 over here
with value 10 and then it's also in SS
table 1 over here with the tombstone
value you can see that's just the Red X
with the circle it means that because
the tombstone value is in the more
recent SS table I know that comparing
the two of them I can be certain that
basically the key Jordan has been
deleted assuming it's not in our LSM
tree of course so the other big thing to
note here is that every single one of
these reads that we're going to be
performing for an individual key is O of
log n right because in an LSM tree this
is a balanced binary search stream so we
know that we're reaching logarithmic
time complexity when finding a key
additionally for all of these SS tables
on disk the really nice thing is that
they're already sorted and so because of
the fact that they're sorted it means
that you can go ahead and binary search
them for the proper value of your key so
binary search of course means that you
know we're starting here let's say uh we
have an A and A Z over here and we're
looking for key e right so the letter in
the middle of the alphabet is going to
be k or something like that and then we
say oh shoot you know we're looking for
K so now we're going between a and K uh
oh wait uh you know now we've got uh D
oh wait we want e which is between D and
K so now let's look over here and
eventually we find our row right so
that's binary search that's logarithmic
complexity
okay so I've basically said to you now
recall that every single time we do a
read we first check the LSM tree then we
check all of our SS tables on disk in
the order that they were submitted or
basically rather reverse chronological
order so what we're going to actually go
ahead and get into now are some LSM tree
optimizations right because that read
process that I've described the loan can
actually take a pretty long time and so
there are a few things that we can do to
speed this up especially as it pertains
to the tables on disk so the first thing
that we can do is actually add something
called a sparse index so let's imagine I
have an SS table here and basically all
it has is all names right let's imagine
every single person that has ever been
received a name from A to Z is in This
Ss table well what we can do is actually
create something known as a sparse index
where we take certain keys out of that
SS table and write their uh basically
their location on disk so by putting all
of these right here see we have Adam
Jordan Sam and Quincy we can actually
get started on our binary search a
little bit faster so if I know that um
you know the name that I want is between
a and j right I'm looking for Dan I know
that I only have to binary search
between the locations for Adam and
Jordan and that is going to speed up our
query because it skips out on a couple
iterations of binary search which is
really great so that's going to help us
a lot for reads and again it doesn't
take up a lot of space on disk because
this index is sparse it's not containing
all of the keys just some of them so we
actually have an index for our SS table
in addition to that we can do something
else called a bloom filter now the bloom
filter itself is something that I'm
going to cover in a separate video
because it kind of deserves its own
video it's a really cool kind of
probabilistic data structure but
basically the gist of it here is the
bloom filter allows us to say whether a
key is not in a table right so basically
you know if I'm looking through the name
Tech lead in This Ss table I can't
imagine anyone has actually been legally
named Tech lead unless he is that would
be wild and so of course our bloom
filter would just go ahead and say no
it's not in there now this isn't going
to be 100 accurate right if it happens
to say that the key may be in there it
could be wrong but all of these no's
basically means that we can skip out on
searching this particular SS table and
that again is going to speed up our
query
okay so finally we've gotten through all
of our LSM table specific details but
there's just one last issue I've
mentioned so far that there's no
explicit deletions of keys right we just
have this concept of a tombstone and
whenever we update a key we're
effectively just adding another copy of
it right into our index so we're going
to potentially be wasting tons of
storage so the last thing to think about
that kind of some of these indexes will
do is perform a step known as compaction
so you can see that I've drawn up on the
iPad screen right here these two SS
tables SS table 1 which I'm going to
assume is the more recently written one
and SS table two and you can see that
they each have three students in their
respective scores and the issue is that
the key Alex is duplicated in both let's
imagine the teacher made an error and
then she went ahead and corrected Alex's
score and so now Alex has an updated
score of 93 instead of 91. in reality
there would probably be even more wasted
space than this as opposed to just one
example so let's go ahead and perform
compaction
what we're going to first do is start
with basically two pointers right and
they're going to start at the zeroth
index of both of these SS table arrays
I'm now going to compare the two of them
I see Alex from SS table 1 and SS table
2. as you can see Alex from SS table 1
is the same as Alex from SS table 2
because they have the same key but since
s is table 1 is more recent the value
Alex with 93 is going to win and that is
why we have 93 in our new combined SS
table
next we're going to move the pointer
ahead on s's table 1 since we selected
that value
and we're going to actually do the same
on SS table 2 since it was actually a
duplicate so now we have Bob compared to
Dan Bob is going to be the lower key
hence we have Bob here we're going to do
the same thing now with Dan not moving
forward and we're going to compare
Charlie to Dan as you can see Charlie
again is lower so that's why Charlie
comes in and then finally We'll add Dan
and Edward from the other table that is
how we can go ahead and actually keep
the resulting list from our two SS
tables sorted and of course that is
going to be in O of n complexity you can
go ahead and check this problem out on
lead code you're literally just merging
to sorted lists okay so let's go into
some conclusions to talk about because
we've gone over three types of indexes
now which are the main ones that I
wanted to address for this series and I
want to kind of make an overarching
statement about what's good for which
use case so let's start out with the
hash index since that's what we did
first and hopefully you guys have a good
sense of that now so the great thing
about the hash index is that because
it's in memory and because it's a hash
map it is super super fast we have o of
one reads and writes in memory now the
rights are obviously going to get a
little bit slower due to that right
ahead log but at the end of the day this
is going to be the fastest in terms of
performance for just individual key
reads and writes that being said there
are two main downsides the keys need to
fit in memory because our index is just
in memory and also there are no range
queries allowed we've said that hash
maps are really really not good for
dealing with range queries and if you
want to deal with range queries you
probably have to figure out a way to
sort your data
so that is kind of where our B tree
comes in now this is kind of the
standard index and a lot of relational
databases we'll cover what a relational
database is in a future video but
basically the advantages of a b tree is
that you can get really fast range
queries right everything is co-located
to the basically similar keys on disk if
I have a key atom and I have a key Alex
they're going to be very close together
on disk and they're going to be far from
the key Zachary at the same time the
rights are actually going to be pretty
slow because they're going straight to
disk unlike the hash index where writes
are in memory having to go through a few
iterations of a tree on disk and
ultimately make it right is probably
pretty slow so the B tree definitely
really sacrifices on rights there but
again the main advantage is this is
actually feasible for big data sets you
can actually keep all of your keys on
disk as opposed to having to keep them
all in memory and then kind of the last
big thing here is of course the LSM tree
which we've just spoken about so you can
see I actually have a couple of white
points here the reason for that being
that they're kind of the middle ground
between the B tree and the hash index so
basically the main kind of pro point for
the LSM tree is of course that you're
not limited by the size of ram in your
computer in terms of how many keys you
can store at the same time we have a
couple of kind of mediocre points on one
hand compared to B trees the rights are
going to be fast that's because they're
going to memory of course there is a
right ahead log involved which is going
to make rights a little bit slower but
at the end of the day just know that
rights to LSM tree indexes are faster
than b trees of course though they are
going to be slower than the hash index
that's because even though you're
writing to memory for both writing to a
hash map is going to be faster than
writing to a binary search tree just
based on time complexity alone
additionally another great thing about
the LSM tree that we didn't cover in too
much depth is that it supports range
queries this is because all of our SS
tables have sorted keys right so it
means that all of the keys that are
similar to one another are going to be
close to one another in our SS tables
however of course as with just a normal
read query four range queries we're
going to also have to read all of those
SS table files and by doing so it means
that those range queries are going to be
slower than just a simple B tree range
query where we only have to do one read
and of course kind of the last big deal
in all of this is compaction we've
mentioned compaction so far as a way to
kind of reduce the amount of disk space
that we've used and effectively because
of compaction we are going to be doing
some background CPU usage in order to
merge those SS table files together
all right guys I hope you enjoyed this
video I'm doing my best to kind of make
these as comprehensive as possible and
as always I hope you have a great day